well in London the Metropolitan Police
of today confirmed that sir
36 people were arrested for offences
including violent disorder criminal
damage and assaulting officers we can
speak now to the London mayor said he
can't he joins me from South London
thanks for joining us
first of all do you agree with Boris
Johnson that the black lives matter
protests were subvert it by thuggery no
that's not the language that I'd use yes
I'm disappointed and angry but a police
officer says in London who were doing
their job keeping the police were
injured and were on the receiving end of
some acts of criminal violence that is
unacceptable but what I saw this weekend
from my home was thousands and thousands
of people protesting peacefully lawfully
and by and large safely because they
feel really angry but in 2020
black people in particular I stood at
the receiving end of racism
discrimination and equality and the two
things that are brought to the fore
their concerns around they saw the
brutal killing of George Floyd but also
the unequivocal evidence that kovat 19
has had a disproportionate impact on
black Asian minority I think people and
what I hope that Prime Minister would be
doing is focusing on addressing this
racism this discrimination and this
inequality this that exists in our great
country bottles were thrown at police
unarmed police officers were forced to
flee for their own safety presumably you
condemn any violence against the police
unequivocally forty-nine brave officers
doing their job keeping the peace were
injured and assaulted unacceptable I've
met officers on a daily basis who run
towards terrorists and dangerous things
and keep the rest of us safe I've met
brief families who've lost their police
officer brothers and sons in the line of
their duty I've got nothing but respect
for a police is unacceptable to attack
our police what I'm making this mark is
that the bigger story is the fact that
thousands and thousands of Britons black
white asian men
women old young I think black lives
matter and notwithstanding this global
pandemic which makes it dangerous to
leave your home are willing to do so I
had are protesting peacefully lawfully
and safely yeah I think what he means by
subverted by thuggery is that there are
those who are using these protests as an
excuse to attack the police do you
accept that well you know I accept that
I small minority of people back in
acting badly are detracting from what is
a really important issue here which is
the fact that in 2020 the world were
just minnesota and minneapolis not just
in the USA around the world including
our country black people are still the
received land of racism inequality and
discrimination of course is unacceptable
if a small minority detract from this
really important issue and by the way my
advice which is I've made quite clear
and unambiguous is people shouldn't be
protesting because we're in the middle
of a global pandemic but they are it's
really important to follow the advice
which is to try and keep it social
distance you know where a face covering
try keep teen years apart
use hand sanitizer during the course of
the day while she hands readily and
thoroughly where you can or what you
must not be doing of course is breaking
the law in the way that you've still
shown by your images in London yeah the
Met Police your police are they
legitimate targets of peaceful protest
given what's happened in the United
States and what's happened historically
here maybe know that the police mustn't
be targeted look we've got 31,000
officers who work their socks off gained
out they're under resourced they're
overstressed they've seen over the last
10 years massive cuts they've had
colleagues who've lost their lives and
we've seen this weekend and last weekend
14 officers injured it's not acceptable
yes of course people have legitimate
concerns about the use of excessive
police force around the world include in
our country of course there are concerns
legitimate concerns around
disproportionality not just in policing
in the prison service around the
sentences judges give around that I love
black people excluded from schools
issues that arise from
antenatal care all the way to mortality
Pisa which is my issues to be addressed
they come to us why it's unhelpful when
the Prime Minister leads with language
like thuggery how can the police though
it must be very difficult for them I
think is the point I'm gonna make how
can they crack down on the violence that
we did witness when police brutality was
at the very heart of the the reason for
the protest I think we're in danger of
completing two issues one is the general
concerns of public half around racism
discrimination and inequality 2 is a
police been able to police a peaceful
lawful safe processed our police
officers who are working this weekend on
Saturday and Sunday didn't there was no
justification for them being attacked
and it's really important the police
will carry their investigation if any
person this evidence of Kamiya criminal
acts against our police in London action
will be taken
there's a separate important issue which
that we as a society got to examine the
racism that exists in all walks of life
in our country in 2020 but you seen
policing looks the criminal justice
system in education when it comes to
with a grim great with more likely
victims of crime the fact that when it
comes to media when it comes to our
boardrooms when it comes to politics
when it comes to our cabinet there are
too few black people in there yeah
absolutely
you're the Cenotaph someone tried to set
fire to the to the flags on the Cenotaph
the Churchill statue was defaced these
are very very important to many many
people in this country why are you not
doing more to protect them yeah we saw
we we are and firstly again condemn
unequivocally particularly as this
weekend we were commemorating the d-day
landings we're looking at all relevant
statutes in our city to make sure that
they are properly protected and we can't
have a situation where the Cenotaph and
flags are our attacked again unequivocal
condemnation from me and City Hall the
police will be reviewing with us what we
can do to keep the Cenotaph the statue
of Winston Churchill and other things
safe and I just think this to anybody
who was responsible for the criminal
damage
you are detracting from what is such an
important issue
your detracting from what is an issue
that we're discussing around the world
people in
of power influence and by you doing that
not only have you committed an act of
criminal damage but you've met there
other than me talking with you and sky
about black lives matter I'm talking
about this yeah just you know while
they're on the Bristol issue would did
you I mean the Home Secretary is called
utterly disgraceful what happened to the
statue there do you think it was utterly
disgraceful and you understand that
state she a statue coming down I think
our Home Secretary and our prime
minister should try and walk in the
shoes of a black person in Bristol who
on a daily basis STIs somebody
commemorated celebrated who was a slaver
who was responsible for their ancestors
being enslaved responsible for Britain
to this country 84,000 slaves and around
the world and thrown overboard 20,000
innocent black women and children and I
find the lack of empathy from a prime
minister and a Home Secretary
breathtaking and just finally there was
a report out last week outlining the
threat of covert 19 specifically and
disproportionately to black and ethnic
minorities it didn't come up with
recommendations
what are you many of these workers on
the frontline on London Transport what
are you doing to help them to do risk
assessments and what recommendations are
you making to them because they will be
looking to you for advice well I I
thought the government's review was the
reason words carefully a whitewash what
I've done is not simply an equivalent
evidence that there is a personality but
make changes so we have now carried out
risk assessments of all our people not
just in City Hall budgets in transport
not just in the police service and in
the fire service we're making sure we
have proper risk assessments with that
includes taking off the front mind
people who should be shielded we've also
made sure that we're keeping all our
staff safe by having measures that are
above and beyond advice by experts we've
got world leading experts from UCL
denoted London looking at what we're
doing to give us real-time change to be
made and I'm really pleased as a
consequence of me lobbying the
using human rights commission will now
be a statutory investigation into the
disparate nature of coronavirus covered
1930 second it should you be removing
some of them from jobs that are public
interfacing and frontline we've been
working right about with trade unions to
make sure staff who are at risk are
removed for the front line so as we
speak I think two thousand plus of our
bus drivers are shielding for a variety
of reasons to do with their age
underlying health conditions we go I
think have a not just a moral duty of
care but actually illegal do difficut to
look at what's happened in relation to
the evidence to make sure everyone is
safe and that's one of the reasons why
I'm surprised the government doesn't
understand the feeling people have in
relation to black lives matter but just
George Floyd but the impacts of curvy
nineteen on black people appreciate your
time thanks very much